[Music]
skin problems are always nutritional
deficiency diseases obviously there's
some certain infections but 99% of the
time things that don't respond to
medical approaches or nutritional
deficiencies and invariably their
secondary nutritional deficiencies
meaning the person has usually gluten
intolerance they can't have wheat barley
round oats if they do eat wheat barley
and rye notes they get it contact
enteritis and this causes our intestines
inflamed some daughters will call it
leaky gut syndrome celiac disease
appendicitis diverticulitis here laval
syndrome inflammatory bowel disease
we're talking about things like Crohn's
disease all of these are due to gluten
intolerance well at that point you
cannot absorb nutrients particularly the
omega-3 essential fatty acids which
results in asthma as well as things like
dermatitis eczema psoriasis rosacea on
the face and your intestines look like
your skin does and you have to get off a
gluten all 90 essential nutrients you
have to take the 16 mineral 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids 3 essential
fatty acids I would take extra of the
omega-3 essential fatty acids the EFA
pluses take three of those twice a day
for 100 pounds of body weight and eczema
nazma dermatitis and asthma psoriasis
and asthma rosacea nazma usually go away
and anywhere from 3 to 4 months
I want to talk about male pattern
baldness in both men and women
I believe I've run across one of the
most effective ways to reverse male
pattern baldness most men and women I
was starting to have the problem myself
even though I'm supplementing very
heavily we know from a big study at
Kyoto University that tin deficiency
especially in laboratory animals will
cause a male pattern baldness and it
doesn't matter if it's mice or rats or
rabbits or guinea pigs or hamsters or
dogs you get a male pattern baldness
regardless of gender when it comes to
tin deficiency you replete Tim give him
ten back and they grow their hair back
well I've been really pumping the tin in
competent in and it wasn't get the
results I was looking for in fact I was
starting to lose hair of my arms and I
was getting concerned about that and
suddenly now I was getting symptoms of
gluten intolerance is kind of like eat a
pretzel or something and get all itchy
so I gave up gluten I mean I gave up
gluten I mean I don't even go into a
householder to have a dog eat and dry
dog food and by giving up gluten hair
started growing back up my arms of
course I was still taking an enormous
amount of ten and the 90 for life I've
been taking the 90 for life twice a day
for 65 years but I want to think back
about it as a kid I did have some
symptoms of gluten intolerance but
nobody obviously picked it up and so
forth and over time when you look around
and you say you know what cultures on
earth really don't have problems with
baldness gray hair or that kind of stuff
it turns out when you look at the
Japanese and you look at the Chinese
they live on rice and millet and
buckwheat and sweet potatoes maybe even
some pumpkins and squash but wheat is
not a big thing for them now we've known
about gluten intolerance since the days
of the Greek philosophers and physicians
back 2,000 years ago
so gluten intolerance is not a new thing
but most people back in the old days ate
buckwheat and millet and that sort of
stuff and wheat wasn't a big part of
their diet until if you go by the
anthropologists they say about ten
thousand years ago when in the Fertile
Crescent which in
what biblically was the Garden of Eden
and since we started introducing wheat
to the Western world Europe and United
States there's more and more more bald
men more and more more bald women I mean
the wig sales are going crazy for both
men and women and I never you know got
into the wig thing but there's a lot of
people who do I know a lot of people who
wear wigs because they have thin here
but you go on a gluten-free diet and you
take the 90 essential nutrients which
includes 10 I'm telling you the hair
grows back on your arms if you're
interested in that guys that gives you a
signal right and also the hair grows
back your head I've had so many people
say to me doc are you wearing a wig
you're starting to grow out of here I
said I'm gonna wearing a wig it's just
coming back and look at my arms I'm
looking like a hairy ape here the hair
is coming back on my arms and everybody
regardless of gender
you take the 90 essential nutrients if
you're beginning to get thinning here a
lot of people say men my hairbrush is
just loaded with hair of clogging up the
drain in the bathtub with hair every
time I take a shower it's just falling
out well you get on a gluten-free diet
you take the 90 essential nutrients
which is very rich in ten and guess what
you'll be amazed I've seen it and
probably about a dozen people now I've
been kind of tracking that with them and
sure enough places where I was as bald
as a bowling ball I mean a bowl bald as
a billiard bowl I mean I didn't have a
single hair and hair is coming back in
quite a striking way and I didn't have a
whole lot of gray hair ahead a little
bit on my head a little bit my mustache
but that colors coming back too so it
took me a while to heal my intestines
because I've been eating gluten all my
life you know I'm using the Chinese
system I'm 74 using the American system
I'm 73 and Counting and I haven't been
to a doctor in 65 years and of course
they wouldn't have gotten it anyway and
so I'm just so excited about this get on
it if you have thin hair you have male
pattern baldness regardless if you're
male or female you get on the ninetieth
sense of nutrients you get on the
healthy start pack one per 100 pounds of
body weight take in all 90 essential
nutrients all 60 essential minerals
which will include 10 and there's all
kinds of other things that 10 will do
for you and
is good for your heart and good for your
skin good for your arteries and veins is
just a great mineral it's one of the
essential minerals one of the 60
essential minerals I get so excited
about it when I make some kind of little
discovery I mean you can go get wigs you
can go do laser treatments you get the
red light you comb your hair with you
can do all kinds of stuff but guess what
you get on a gluten-free diet you take
the 90 essential nutrients which I have
the 10 in it and you're going to be
amazed but give it you know anywhere
from 3 to 6 months 3 to 6 months and if
you're in your 50s and 60s it might take
you 6 months to heal your intestines
enough to be able to absorb sufficient
amounts that tend to make an impact
could that mean gluten free gosh I just
have been gluten free for a good
I mean seriously drop dead gluten free
for 5 years I've been tinkering with
reduced gluten intake for 25 years and
so it really took a quite a while for me
to see that benefit to where I was
getting the hair growing back and it's
just I mean it's like you turn on the
switch and just kind of like going crazy
just like that ad on TV now they're
having a beard growing contest right and
it's just an amazing thing to see hair
grow that fast and that I mean
universally I mean we're talking global
alopecia and a lot of people are they
lose hair their pubic hair under their
arms on their chest their neck all over
their head places you think you should
have hair they lose it and of course
this bothers teenagers see teenagers who
have thinning here and they loser here
you get them on a gluten-free diet you
get them on the 94 live program 1-1
Healthy Start Packer 100 pounds of body
weight and you will make a friend for
life